foreign
our friend Graham Stefan who has been on
the show recently one of the biggest
personal finance YouTubers out there
he's big into real estate that's how he
made his millions super young guy uh
maybe a year or two younger than us and
he posted a video on his YouTube channel
titled my tenant just trashed my house
and we've got a video of what the inside
of that house looks like so if you're
watching on YouTube you can peruse that
but we'll give you the play-by-play it's
not pretty it looks like a like a
college dorm room oh look at that just
crap everywhere kitchen's destroyed he's
walking through pointing everything out
and so these people just moved out is
that what the I I hope to God they don't
live there anymore I'm guessing they
were addicted all of that stuff in the
closet oh it looks like a hoarder
nightmare situation if they like moved
out and then they left all of this in
the rental and they're like so gross
what happened James James is agreeing oh
man this is dark the dark reality of
passive income everywhere stuff all in
every cabinet and every door oh
you know what's extra sad this was a
long-term tenant of his 10 years he
never raised the rent because they were
such a good tenant up until they
apparently weren't well until they left
slash didn't because they left all their
crap behind
the nightmare discontinues just stuff
everywhere I mean the amount of clean
he's gonna need a cleanup crew just to
deal with this matter yes well you take
the security deposit if you ever got one
10 years ago for sure that will start to
cover it keep that so the advice around
real estate investing artist sounds
insane and it's pay cash for your
investment properties because you're not
factoring in Risk yep and the hope is
I'm gonna put nothing down and I'm going
to charge them more rent than the
mortgage is worth I'm going to take the
spread and I'm gonna make five thousand
dollars a year ten thousand dollars a
year right that's usually the margins
when people call into the show I haven't
done everything yeah after all of their
expenses yeah you're not making a
full-time income from one property
that's right so yeah so starting off
small
and you know obviously this Market looks
a whole lot different
um and it's hard to get a good deal but
always mostly the for me buying real
estate when you go in to invest into it
the money's made at the sale like you
like when you buy a property that's
where the equity should be you should be
able to get a deal so such a good deal
pay market rate no so you already have
automatic Equity
um yeah and start small and again I know
this was in a different world but even
for for Winston uh and myself my husband
and I when we we bought a condo it was
in short sale in Nashville over in
Nippers Corner area if you know where
that is the
um Old Hickory Boulevard and uh I don't
know but you know some people know and
yeah we bought it in short sale and I
mean it was a few tens of thousands of
dollars back then it wasn't a lot and it
was kind of not it was nasty so we had
to go in and kind of fix it up and we've
rented it and kept it for about eight
years and got so much equity and ended
up selling it to help pay for the house
that we built and it was it was it was a
great
um it was a great experience
mostly because we paid cash we got a
deal on sale we didn't go big right it
was just a condo uh but it was in a
growing part of Nashville it wasn't
really in a hot area but it was in a
growing area and then we were able to
use that asset later for our primary
residence when we wanted to build and
helped use that to fund it so so all
that to say it can be done well if you
start small it doesn't have to be big in
Grands and right now it's probably not
the market to find a great deal there
might be some foreclosures and short
sales coming up but as of now like it's
it's probably not a great uh it's not a
great Market to get a great deal yeah
and a lot of people are looking into
what's called house hacking which is not
really a hack you just buy a house and
then someone else lives there too yeah
and they help cover the mortgage so not
it's not a New Concept and you've seen a
lot of people want to buy duplexes and
triplexes and live in one living one and
rent the others out but guess what
you're not the first one to think of
that and so they're actually in really
high demand which means people are going
to be will willing to pay more than you
are to get that property which means
you're not getting a deal so it's always
it sounds better in theory and on paper
than it is in reality and you're not
thinking about well what if the HVAC
goes out and also I have an HVAC 2 I've
got to worry about so yeah you better
have that house has to have its own
emergency fund to cover those repairs
and you better have good landlord
insurance to cover more than just the
property there's a lot of risk involved
that that can help cover uh and on top
of that
you you can't guarantee there's going to
be a renter no and you can't guarantee
they're going to pay and take care of
your property and we saw this with covid
there's a moratorium on evictions yeah
so you could just not pay your rent and
the landlord can't do anything about it
yes so yeah there's you know again we
love real estate when it comes to
investing I think it's a really smart
thing I think when you're to the point
that you're diversifying more than just
um retirement accounts uh I think it's
great I mean I because it goes up in
value it's a it's a great it is a great
investment but it's just uh you want to
move a whole lot smaller slower 10 times
slower than what the culture is saying
right now the culture's like get in it's
not a big deal and then if you have your
primary mortgage and now this mortgage
and then someone doesn't pay and then
the HOA comes in I mean it's just it can
be a disaster and it's a part-time job I
mean if you have tenants like you're at
their beck and call if something happens
as a landlord and so you just have to
know all of that going in so it's a lot
of work and a lot of dedication it's
worth it if you do it the right way
but that's the problem is it seems like
everyone's fast tracking it and it's and
you're you're adding risk when you go
into debt for it and even paying a cut
to a property management company it's
still not passive there's still work to
be done there's still a lot of
communication back and forth and you've
got to keep your eye on these properties
I've got family friends that didn't do
their due diligence when screening
tenants and they didn't have a bank
account and they stopped paying rent and
then they can't evict them and then
they've set up drug rooms in there you
just don't know what these tenants are
doing it's a true story Rachel that's
all I can disclose at this time no but
uh Graham's video is about 10 minutes
long but we just wanted to play you his
quick takeaway at the end of this
horrific situation let's see that clip I
gotta say even with a management company
owning a rental property is not truly
passive income and it requires a
consistent amount of work if you're
expected to be successful at it
there you go that sums it up in the
nutshell that sums it up thank you so
much Graham and uh congrats on all the
success he's had in the real estate
world yeah with your current house
though I want that even when you think
you're a great tenant and we want to
believe the best of people you know as
landlords tenants out there I mean we we
tell you people Everyone listening like
rent if you yeah if you have debt and
all that so like it's I think renting is
great and there are great tenants out
there but no one treats it as well as
you are you know it's not their it's not
their house for sure like a rental car
you know when we travel more car you
just kidding I don't know rental cars
Rachel just throwing wrappers in the
background you just drive it like you
wouldn't drive your own and your minivan
has no goldfish on the floor if you keep
that thing clean [ __ ] and span wow [ __ ]
and span well there you go if you want
to get into real estate by the way this
is this is the time and place to do it
you've got to be completely debt free
home and everything and then save up
cash and buy it that investment property
and I know that's you're like George
that's a 10-year it may be a 10-year
Journey but guess what your risk is so
minimal comparatively to having a giant
mortgage and you've got to make that
payment every month that mortgage lender
whether or not your tenant pays you or
not so that's a scary situation to be in
so do this wisely
and don't just blindly follow some guy
on Tick Tock who's doing the Burr method
and we're just gonna buy it with nothing
down and then we're gonna refinance and
do the cash out and put that on the next
one it sounds so fancy and in reality
it's how a lot of people go broke and
stay broke
so don't do this stuff do it the slow
way be a crock pot in a world full of
microwaves because it only takes one
extra second and that in that microwave
Rachel for that popcorn to burn and
everything's not gonna burn no no no no
mine's good to go never know don't do it
crock pot it Rachel did this this week
with chili turned out great didn't it so
good there you go America this is the
Ramsay show